all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing I should probably clear out
the the friend chat all right hello
everyone how are you guys doing hope you
guys are having a wonderful day and
today we are here with another money
another money-making episode I think
this is episode number 11 or 12 but uh
this one's a little different than the
rest this one has no skill SL Quest
requirements the only requirement that
you need is money you just have to have
some money you don't have to have a ton
the more you have the more of these
things that you will be able to buy and
then use so obviously it is helpful as
with everything in the game the more
money you have the more money you make
but with this you'll still be making
decent money even with lower cash tacks
and I'm hoping to kind of show that to
you guys in this video so what you're
going to need is just whatever cash you
can amount personally I have five mil
right here and uh I'm going to go to the
GE with it because that's where we make
all of our money right I mean if there
was like really good collecting or like
pvm like money-making methods you'd
already know about it so you kind of
have to exploit the GE as much as you
can I'm going to try and block out yeah
I'm just going to I'm going to squeezing
the screen on this so I can block out my
other merch that I have currently going
on so I'm sorry about that but uh here
we go so going to go ahead and buy what
we need to buy so here's what we're
going to have all right so tooth half of
a key this and we're just going to keep
it in our minds what this is worth all
right I'm going to have to end up buying
this so give me a second all right so
there we go I'm I'm zoomed in up here so
you guys can't see my item again but uh
here we go so basically what I have
going on here is I bought and sold the
tooth half margins as you guys can see
right here so this is what you'll end up
buying your tooth and loop PA for so
you're going to want to buy them for the
sell prices and in total you'll be
spending
28.2k to go ahead and make a key now I'm
going to go see what we would be able to
sell on a key for all right so selling
on the keys pretty much what the money
that you will be selling it for will be
whatever you buy it for it'll be the
opposite of what you did with the two
hav so here we go and as you guys can
see here
29.7k there are typically bigger margins
earlier I was Finding about a 2K margin
however this is still 1.5k which is
pretty decent this isn't the most you'll
ever get so I will up the profit that
you can make with this and I mean
assuming I find a better margin
throughout this video but we'll check it
out all right so there we go from there
I have found my margin so I'm going to
go ahead and spend these five mill that
I currently have on the half Keys all
right so there we go we have almost all
of our money at work um I could be able
to buy one more key but whatever um so
we have 175 buying I'm going to go see
how long it takes for all these to buy
um one thing I would recommend when
doing this though is do not undercut
people cuz a lot of the people like me
that are doing this are constantly at
the GE so I mean they they'll be able to
change their margins just as well as you
can so you may as well just stay away
from it and just uh you know slowly let
them buy all right so I kept getting
undercut on the loop PA so we ended up
having to overspend for the final 13 but
there we go we're about four off so I'm
going to go
ahead sell off one of these God damn it
I hate myself and there we go so we got
2.2k left and in total I guess we have
176 keys to put together so I'm going to
go ahead and see how long this takes me
to do it shouldn't be long at all and
see how much money we make in such a
short amount of time all right finished
it off and that is a whole three minutes
that I ended up spending so I believe I
had
176 if I am correct which I hope I am
and uh yeah I think I think I think
we're good to go with that one um so
yeah give me one second all right so I
was correct in saying that I had 176 I
just had to go back and make sure but
let's go ahead we'll get out 22k and uh
we'll see what we can do actually first
I'm going to grab 30k and just insta buy
one I'm going to bank it but I'm just
seeing what the margin is and there we
go all right so it is going to sell on
for Med price so let's go ahead we will
Bank this and uh yeah grab out our 2.2k
can't forget about that I think I
actually missed some GP there like 70 GP
or something think we'll be fine but
we're gonna sell these all on for Med so
as you guys can see those will into to
sell all right so what you want to see
here is that I made pretty much
230k within 3 minutes and I know that
there was some buying and selling that
had to go into that but realistically if
you did this overnight and stuff like
that it's hugely profitable it may not
be the best right after this video so I
just want you guys to remember that so
230k is what we'll be able to sell them
on for as you guys saw I did insta buy
one so it will sell with time
but that'll be it for this video I know
that this is like I I understand things
with these methods that like and I think
people just think I'm stupid and just
don't get it that these things aren't
things you can do for an hour I know
there are things that you can't do for
an hour which is why in the title it'll
be how to make 230k in 3 minutes if I
actually thought you could do this for
an hour then I put it as an hour but
there's no way that I could sell this
off as a like 6 mil an hour 4 to 5 mil
an hour method because you can never
keep that up but uh hope you guys
enjoyed the video If you guys did make
sure to leave that like if you guys have
any way that you think I can improve or
anything you guys want to tell me about
comment about it down below you want to
see these videos as soon as they go live
in the future hit the sub button down
below really helps out the channel uh I
got a Twitter in the description if you
guys want to know more about me and uh
you can always hit me up in game either
either either hit me up through PM or
you can join my clan chat not really
mine but a friend of mine 07 helpers and
uh yeah that'll be it for me to day hope
you guys have a wonderful day and peace
look at what the is that side note
at the end shout out to 147 what's going
on boy um they all sold so for anyone
that's like oh they probably didn't sell
you just kept them in there and told us
you made money just kidding I love you
[Music]
me